welcome to this video playing a chess
game hi is called Joan with hamburger a
club probably that's not the background
of this handle but yeah let's see we get
to see every name mark wacht ich einen
ok so we got an I wanted to play the
patrol and actually but ok this is the
line that i recently saw Quincy to
played by Iranian Grandmaster aliana off
its playing Queen c2 and looked you Mon
funny enough the idea is to later black
goes for f5 to put Nigeria and then all
of a sudden if the night only six
appears I interesting here maybe I can
just take such an idea I mean it's not
necessary but may be interesting rook t1
for trying to go for see 5 or c5
immediately see 5d 595
civi will mean yes to go d5 now
otherwise it's it's really bad so d 5 95
96 defaults it's maybe possible I can
take d5 take the five night eat XD five
hmm batik e5 Knight 64 I'm not sure how
good this is that looks looks a bit
strange to be honest what about the moon
flag will give one actually it's may be
interesting maybe try that maybe you can
just play Quincy seven I don't know I'm
totally new to this position just
experimenting here a little bit with
Quincy to cannot so just play before
yeah maybe i'll be sure to 5pm every
dunno i have no idea it looks
interesting very m complicated central
struggle yeah here Knight takes d5 as a
move Queenie five then F form but it's
not really really leading to much I
don't know maybe I should take some some
time taking with the pot I have not be
five that's it's really bad I guess not
completely sure
here I was thinking 94 to d6 but quite
obviously it's complicated even Bishop
f5 is a move wanted going to h4 looks
wrong I mean just miss placing the
bishop yeah I can jump to the six now
let's do that it's not that terrible for
black in itself this is a good night but
you can go night at five even though
really
it looks really weakening but maybe it's
not that bad
want to prepare before and get be to
protected not sure about it very very
difficult position k IE 4 i'd like to
answer that with 94 that much is clear
but i don't know if i if i can maybe i
can with this smooth night f4 i have
Bishop c4 it's not not such a big
problem yeah I'm down on time the
position is quite ok I think not much to
complain about at least that's my
impression it's very complicated quite
obviously so easily possible that they
overlook stuff g-form
q g4 I was thinking probably not
let's get this in 93 I wanted to take on
e6 but it's not doing anything here
against that okay I always have no idea
form well very very difficult to play
time morning I wasn't under this I liked
I liked for me those traits i think
should help me to coordinate
if it takes on c4 I can do this do this
pre move
or with the Queen actually but ok night
take this probably better just
controlling me five maybe here Quincy
tc4 was really better maybe it's really
hard to tell here in this position I
don't mind 93 I'll just give up the
exchange of course those nights are
definitely worth giving up the exchange
I would love to enter on the e-file but
not sure how to do it rookie one it's
not not so easily playable cannot maybe
maybe I should play Queen d2 22 for
rookie one I have caught up on the clock
quite a bit and we'll get three oven
this kind of thing
something to see three may be coming or
ruka fade yeah yeah I don't know Queen
trade is debatable probably this was a
good idea probably it wasn't I can take
you for now check
check jam hard to do it in 10 seconds or
something what we have here there's no
tactic I cannot believe it on the king
with all those nights check check check
nope okay white reason yeah maybe I can
be known time but this is just
ridiculous ah jam I mean very difficult
game around here I think probably what
should be somewhat better but it was
very very tricky to play Knight a5 yeah
maybe I just wanted to give up the
exchange but okay I was overlooking this
tactic here this would have been very
difficult to say the least came here I
mean I just I'm just interested in when
here it was a very much time scramble 95
was winning here okay yeah i'm
interested in the position somewhat
later on where i was really very curious
if there is not any technique hanging on
like here's there nothing that I can do
against the king it seems like that yeah
two nights and rook that it looks
dangerous but there's I know no tactic
I'm just I'm losing here I mean it's
it's pretty much pointless to analyze
the sequence from here because we both
made so many mistakes that ninety five
wins here Queen d4 here like was better
just better but he had 96 is good again
right f7 is winning and so on a desk
tons of mistakes you have you really
cannot play a play well with with 20
seconds on a clock end and the kind of
chaotic position really really
impossible okay
thanks for watching